[موسيقى]
تبقى بجبيني ايه الله اكبر محمول يلي حمل
رايه مستشهد انت لدين تبقى بجبيني اي راسي
رفع د وبروح جمره غضا
والراي ساخن يا ابني واسط
العين وبايع دني
لحسين
يا ابن محرز بغيرته فاضل يا شاين وقالبي
بعد شايل وين ملتقى شايل قلبي بعد شايل
وين ملتقان
وين
نا اقبل بان تكون دمائنا ودماء ابنائنا
واخوان نا ماده في سوق النخاسه
السياسيه ومن هذا الموقع نشد على يد السيد
الرئيس رئيس الوزراء بان يقوم بكل ما عليه
من اجل الدفاع عن سيادته وكرامه وعز
العراق ولن يكون ذلك الا بمغادره هذه
القوات لارض العراق تتطهر ارض العراق من
كل وجود اجنبي لا يمكن ان نقبل بهذه
الحاله لا يمكن ان نقبل بان يقتل ابناؤنا
ونقوم بعمليه التشيع والتامين فقط هذا ما
لا نرضاه ولا نقبله
ابدا